the liberal Global Elite have descended
from their private jets into a luxurious
little town high up in the Swiss Alps
for the annual meeting of the world
economic Forum where they hope to plan
how all the rest of us will live but if
you say that you will be called a crazy
right-wing conspiracy theorist unless
you're John Kerry when you stop and
think about it it's pretty extraordinary
that we select group of human beings
because of whatever touched us at some
point in our lives are able to sit in a
room and come together
and actually talk about saving the
planet I mean it's so almost
extraterrestrial to think about quote
saving the planet if you said that to
most people most people they think
you're just a crazy tree-hugging Lefty
liberal you know do-good or whatever and
and there's no relationship but really
that's where we are
for the record John I do not think that
you people are do-gooders I think you
are do batters okay I am half convinced
that you are all extraterrestrials but I
am I am not convinced about the
do-gooder thing what I'm most convinced
about that John Kerry said is that these
people are Elite they are a select group
of people who have a select past the
caviar and they want to become the
masters of our Collective future but if
you say that you will be called a crazy
right-wing conspiracy theorist
unless you're the founder of the world
economic Forum Klaus Schwab what does it
need to master the future
I think
to have a platform
where all stakeholders of global Society
are engaged
governments business civil societies
Young Generation and I could go on
I think is the first step
to
meet all the challenges
this is how we will Masters the future
so what we know from their own words is
their Elites they meet up in a wealthy
inaccessible ski resort Town surrounded
by the Swiss military and the private
police force and they intend to reorder
the entire world if you acknowledge all
those things to celebrate them
that's perfectly fine then you are an
insightful participant in the
Progressive Society of the future but if
you point out those facts to criticize
them you are a conspiracist kook and a
danger to mankind a lot of kooky stuff
being talked about at the world economic
forum
this is my favorite though
you know they talk about how we're going
to eat the bugs it's not a conspiracy
theory that's from the world economic
Forum website you know they talk about
how we're not going to get to drive our
cars that's not a conspiracy theory
that's from the world economic Forum
website
you know they talk about how we're not
going to own anything we're going to
have no property and we're going to be
really really happy about that not a
conspiracy theory from the world
economic Forum website but but the
agenda item that always seems to pop up
not just among the Davos crowds
specifically at the world economic Forum
but it always pops up among the liberal
Elite
overpopulation
overpopulation the idea
that there were too many people in the
world we got to stop having any more
babies we gotta Maybe
hurry along the people who were already
in the world to their final destination
here
that remains a top agenda item even as
it has been disproven time and time
again for 50 years now disproven
the world economic Forum admits this
that overpopulation has been kind of
disproven and then doubles down on it
anyway they say even as birth rates
decline
overpopulation remains a global
Challenge and they they have this graph
here it says Malthus didn't see this one
coming referring to the malthusian idea
that there are too many people in the
world and we need to reduce the
population they say the vision of a
post-apocalyptic overpopulated world has
been a favorite nightmare scenario of
Science Fiction writers and filmmakers
for decades but data from a variety of
sources including the UN and the World
Bank indicate that the total number of
live births is falling around the world
including in developing nations
and developed Nations some commentators
have suggested the decrease in fertility
rates is good news for our descendants
in previous generations national birth
rates were high however factors such as
new medicine and improved access to
education for women have dropped
fertility rates despite this though some
regions are still experiencing
significant population growth they're
talking about Africa they're talking
about parts of Asia and so this is a
really big problem and we've got to take
care of that
no one who complains about
overpopulation has ever been the good
guy
ever in history if you are complaining
about overpopulation you are on the bad
team okay
none of the people who complain about
overpopulation are ever volunteering
themselves to to take a ticket off the
ship
right it's always that someone else
shouldn't have life it's always that
someone else should hurry along and die
it's never that they themselves want to
do they want to go to parties and Davos
and they want to have nice drinks and
they want to have a bunch of hookers
apparently according to the reports
coming out of Davos there is just an
army of prostitutes descending on the
town because it's a big party and
there's more money than since going
around definitely more money than virtue
and so while they have their fun and
they eat their fancy foods and they
drink their fancy drinks and they
do various activities with their fancy
ladies of the night they talk about how
you should not even have the right to
live forget about the right to a gas
stove forget about the right to eat beef
instead of crickets forget about the
right to drive your truck instead of
some stupid electric car even the right
to live they are going after
and it's all The Usual Suspects and
what's amazing is is
not just the craziest things that they
say but that they try to ground their
agenda in in
political commentary that seems to have
a kernel of Truth a great example of
this saint Al Saint Al Gore took to
Davos to explain why we've got to cut
back on the oil subsidies
enough already enough
and I don't want to get sidetracked onto
what needs to happen but we need to
scale up climate Finance but we need
desperately to scale down anti-climate
Finance
and we are still subsidizing the burning
of fossil fuels globally at a rate 42
times larger than the subsidies for the
shift toward Renewables and EVS
Etc we need new leadership at the World
Bank we need them to scale up the
leverage and vastly increase the amounts
that are are committed and we need to
rein in the anti-climate activities of
the fossil industry
so a lot of Bluster a lot of we should
do this we should do that we're going to
run
my very unpopular agenda
sure that's typical politics but he made
a positive claim here the claim was that
we subsidize oil
and if you just heard that fact
you'd say well that seems kind of
strange oil is a very profitable
industry why is it that governments
around the world to the tune of what
half a trillion dollars a year are
subsidizing oil that seems corrupt we
should probably stop that until you you
ask the basic question okay
sure we subsidize oil why why do we
subsidize oil
and the reason we subsidize oil is so
that poor people don't freeze to death
in the winter
that's why we subsidize oil
we don't subsidize oil
just because we like the cut of the jib
of the CEO of Exxon Mobil the the people
clamoring for the oil subsidies are are
people who are poor or advocating on
behalf of the poor because people can't
afford to heat their homes people can't
afford to fill their gas tanks
why are we subsidizing oil we have a
national strategic petroleum Reserve is
that is that a subsidy of oil well it is
the state purchasing a lot of oil but
it's for National Defense which of those
things do you want to get rid of you
want the poor people to freeze to death
maybe they do I mean if you're worried
about overpopulation then maybe you do
you say well you know these people they
just need to go away I think of Yuval
Harare he's one of the contributors to
the world economic Forum some people
have called him a kind of philosopher of
the world economic Forum Yuval Harare
has said that in the future there's just
going to be all these useless people
all these useless people out there
who are just sucking up energy and he
was asked how are we going to deal with
these useless people and his answer was
drugs and video games play them full of
drugs keep them kind of busy keep them
kind of happy get them out of the way
that is the view of humanity from the
so-called do-gooders as John Kerry calls
them at the world economic forum and why
do they view Humanity this way because
they're standing way high up in the in
the Alps that's why it goes back to that
old wisdom from G.K Chesterton the old
father Brown stories say don't pray from
the tops of buildings don't pray from
Heights because from Heights people look
very very small people look like bugs
and then you end up wanting to feed them
bugs and wanting them to go away and and
viewing them as a kind of pest that
needs to be exterminated because of the
the Peril of overpopulation when you're
down on the ground when you are a
grounded person when when you're when
you're looking up then you can see the
heavens and you can see that people are
really people and they're full-sized and
they look a lot like you they don't look
a lot like the people who go to Davos at
least not to the people who go to Davos
those people are extraterrestrial as far
as Carrie and the rest of those people
are concerned
[Music]
[Music]